otro revés para el gobierno de pedro
castillo bruno pacheco quien renunció a
su cargo de secretario del palacio
presidencial en medio de una
investigación de la fiscalidad de un
caso de corrupción y tráfico de
influencias está de nuevo bajo la luz de
los proyectores por el hallazgo de una
suma de dinero que cuya procedencia se
desconoce que al secretario del
presidente de la república se le
encuentra en el baño o veinte mil
dólares pacheco afirmó que el dinero era
una combinación de sus ahorros y de su
salario probablemente allí
debe acreditar de dónde vienes pero a mí
eso sí me genera sospecha ya alguien a
su trabajo va con sus veinte mil dólares
desde hace varias semanas el gobierno de
pedro castillo está enfrentando a una
crisis reflejada en la renuncia casi
semanal de funcionarios de su gabinete
las sospechas de corrupción y tráfico de
influencias obligaron a varios ministros
a renunciar a su cargo como el de
defensa walter a la ya la semana pasada
a inicios de mes y tras la designación
de un gabinete en sólo tres meses varios
congresistas de la oposición habían
pedido activar el mecanismo de vacancia
en el congreso para sacar del poder al
presidente castillo al mismo tiempo en
las calles del país protestas estallaron
para rechazar el nuevo gabinete y
también pedir la renuncia del castillo
por ahora la oposición sigue buscando 26
votos entre los legisladores para pedir
la destitución presidencial por
incapacidad total caminan conmigo y pida
me va a casa ante el pueblo